we can move on to something slightly
more serious America's crumbling the
sequester have you guys heard about this
thing basically some budget cuts are
gonna kick are gonna kick in I'm not
gonna give you every little breakdown
about it because it go somewhere else
and find the serious stuff but basically
some budget cuts are kicking in about
eighty-five billion dollars and the
Republicans are saying it's gonna cut
the military Democrats are saying we
gotta raise taxes to take care of it
it's the same old same old fight that
we're always in my question to you guys
is is this just simply how politics now
works that we just get to crisis mode
and then some sort of half-assed
resolution Fred what do you think I came
up with the antigen about ten years ago
that all politics is selfish and it's
based on what Tip O'Neill said when he
was Speaker of the House which was all
politics is local
and that's what it is now you have 535
members of the House and Senate who all
they care about is the next election
period and they're not getting along
they're not doing the kinds of things
they need to do to solve the country's
crisis I'm all for this sequester the
budget cuts let's give it a try I think
government will adjust they're doing all
the scare tactics now that we've always
heard and government doing they did that
in California when proposition 13 I just
think that we should try it and see what
happens
yeah Aaron what do you think can we deal
with the world without government if
they shut down what would happen well
I'd probably be you know just go right
through down a b11 it's season one and
two a lot of free time on my hands if
they well I wrote down a couple things I
was thinking about this basic premise of
like why don't you this why don't you
like everyone's like oh reach out to the
people here's an idea like do you do
party line first constituents or I don't
know what that word is constituency
voters yes honey honey
quit charity no you know what I mean
it's like the people don't want this Wow
here's the thought when you go around
and ask the people who you represent but
no one no one cares about that it's just
like a party line party line party line
and the whole I love these words are so
funny the
sequestration sequestration yes all I
could think of was sequester and
castration if you sequestered all these
people at the threat of castration we
would get things moving in about two
hours it would just be like budget
absolutely Kelly what do you think you
know money money money money money it's
all about money there's too much money
in politics and like you said these
people need to get reelected and the
campaign cycle never quits never stops
so they're always raising money this is
about pleasing the people who really pay
for these elections and the citizens
don't get any say in any of this and and
what I really feel this is all about
ultimately it's at the right and the
left
I mean we're heading towards some sort
of crazy civil war I mean I feel like
this is the Mideast I feel like we now
live in the Mideast as the Palestinian
the Israelis and there's no coming
together there's no talking there's
there's no compromise and I'm like well
let's just you know let's get down to it
you know in a bizarre way I think the
analogy works because it's become like
if you give one inch if you give one
inch of land all you've shown is
weakness and that's so the antithesis
really of what politics is so I think
this is going to be the question that
every week on this show that I'm gonna
deal with here is we all talk about this
we all talk about the money and the
gridlock and and the fine people at the
Young Turks talk about it all the time
but what can we do besides all saying it
now you ran for president of the United
States for the Republicans I wasn't
allowed to announce that until you're
sitting here otherwise you working again
get past security
what do we do about this really besides
you're saying that's the money all the
time what do we do what do people do we
got to start getting along and I fault
Obama for that and I said that and my
campaign and I liked Obama although I
was a maxed out Hillary Clinton donor so
I kind of came around reluctantly but he
needs to to be more of a politician with
the Congress he needs to go reach out to
them Reagan did that right when he was
elected but turn that he didn't invite
Mitch O'Connell to the White House for
18 months for just a one-on-one thing
and then somebody said to me well do you
know Mitch
but do you ever think Mikado really I
mean that's what you got to do that's
what that glad-handing is if you take a
guy like Duval Patrick because the
governor of Massachusetts who he is
great and he's a politician who likes
people and goes you know we've got an
intellectual for president he's a great
speaker but he's not a people person
he's not comfortable
groveling with all these feel like all
we hear stories of we're trying we're
trying were trying
Obama trying in the first four years and
now it seems like he won that this you
know and everyone's like you only have
now one year in your second term to jam
down the entire agenda so now it just it
just I think there's a very simple
solution that is just to split up the
United States very Democrats take the
coasts Republicans take the middle and
we're done what is it about Democrats
that they like to live near water water
in big cities there is thirsty because
we're help we're trying to help
everybody it's maybe because Democrats
want an easy escape in case the
Republicans really do technical
Democrats with their yachts all right
and don't forget bonobos comm is the
official outfitter of the Reuben report
and errcode Reuben report for 20% off
your first purchase